when did you live in uh russia ends the
soviet union what's your memory of that
time well so a number of different times
so i went there i first went there in 69
70.
wow a long time ago and uh
then i lived in uh in leningrad mostly
but also in moscow in 1975.
so it was dayton time um
but it was also a time of
political uncertainty and also
um
hardship you know for russians
themselves you know standing in long
lines i mean you must remember this for
food and for uh
getting anything was almost impossible
was a time when jews
were trying to get out
in fact i just talked to a
friend of mine from those days who i
helped get out and get to boston and the
lovely people who managed to have a good
life
in the united states after they left
but it wasn't an easy time it wasn't an
easy time at all i remember people said
fire to their doors and you know their
daughter was
persecuted in school you know once once
they declared that they wanted to
immigrate and that sort of thing so it
was a very it was a lot of anti-semitism
um
so it was a tough time dissidents you
know
hung out with some dissidents and one
guy was actually killed
we think by the k nobody knows exactly
by the kgb but his art studio was he had
a separate studio in leningrad and saint
petersburg today
you know just a small
studio where he did his art and somebody
set it on fire and we think it was kgb
but you know you never really know
um
and he died in that fire so you know it
was not a it was it was a tough time and
you know you knew you were followed you
knew you were being reported on as a as
a foreign scholar as i was there was a
formal exchange
between the united states and the soviet
union and you know they let me work in
the archives but then you know ivanov
got to work in the
in the
physics lab at rochester or something
like that you know so it was a
it was an exchange which sent
historians and literary people and
some social scientists to russia
and they sent all scientists here to you
know grab what they could from mit and
nice places
how is your russian uh has
do you have any knowledge of russian
language that has helped you to
understand oh yeah yeah i mean i i can
read it fine
and the speaking you know comes and goes
uh depending on whether i'm there or
where i've been there recently or if i
spend some time there because i really
need you know i have russian friends who
speak just russian so
you know when i'm there i then uh you
know i can communicate pretty well i
can't really write it unfortunately i
mean
i mean i can but it's not very good
but i get along fine
what's your fondest memory of the soviet
union of russia friends
friends
it's friends was it you know vodka
involved or is it just was vodka
involved is it a little bit you know i'm
not much of a drinker yeah so i would
they you know they just make fun of me
and
i'd make fun of myself that was easy
enough i don't really like you know a
heavy drink i've done a lot of that yeah
a lot i've done some of that but i never
really enjoyed it and
and would get sick and stuff but um
no it's friends you know one friend i
made
in the dormitory you know it was a
dormitory for foreigners but also
siberians
who had come
you know to
leningrad to study
and so i met a couple of guys and one in
particular from homsk
became a wonderful friend and we talked
and talked and talked outside you know
we would go walk outside because we both
knew they were
you know people were listening and stuff
and he would say well this is he was an
historian you know so we would talk
history and he'd say well this was the
case wasn't it i said no i'm sorry sasha
it wasn't the case it was
you know
we think stalin actually had a role in
killing kirif i mean we're not sure but
he said no i said yeah you know so you
know we had these conversations and he
was a
he was
what i would i don't know if he would
agree with me or not i mean we're still
friends so uh he was uh
he's gonna check that naive maybe he'll
listen to the blog or i'll send it to
him or something he was a kind of naive
marxist feminist
and he thought i was uh you know i was
you know i had this capitalist ideal
he'd say what ideology you have and i
said i don't have an ideology you know i
try to just put together kind of
reason and facts and
accurate stories and try to tell them in
that way no no no no you must you know
you're a bourgeois you know this or that
i said no i'm really not and
and so we would have these talks and
these kind of arguments and then
i mean sure enough
you know uh
but we corresponded for a while and then
he had to stop corresponding because he
became a kind of local official in homsk
and he he sort of migrated more and more
to being a democrat and he was then in
the um you know democratic movement
uh under gorbachev and um
you know and the council people's
deputies which they set up which was you
know
elected
as a as a democrat from homes and had a
political career through the eltson
period
and once putin came along you know it
was over
uh he didn't like putin and you know and
and putin didn't like the elsen people
right who were tried to be some of them
tried to be democrats
and and sasha was one who really did he
just published his memoirs in russian by
the way which are very good i think
um
commander of give last
that's what it's called
it was hard it's hard to translate in
english commander of last but i i mean i
translated it for once this is so
beautiful like the do you find that the
translation is a problem or no it's such
a difference translation is very
difficult with the russian language i
mean it's the only language i know
deeply
except right except english and it seems
like so much is lost of the of the pain
the poetry the beauty of the people is
and translators are to be treasured and
good ones to be just i mean those who
who do the translations you know when
you read
you know things in translation sometimes
they're quite beautiful you know whether
it's russian or polish or german or
anything french
you're traveling to paris
to talk to the the the famous
translators that dostoyevsky tolstoy um
and i'm just going to do a several
conversations with them about like you
could just sometimes just grab a single
sentence and just talk about the
translation that's nice
that's um yeah
and also as you said
i would love to be a fly on the wall
with some of those friends he had
because the perspective on history
non-academic sort of without just as
human beings it's so different yeah from
the united states versus russia
when you talk about the way the world
war ii is perceived and all those kinds
of things it's um
it's fascinating it's a history also has
in it opinion and perspective
and so sometimes stripping that away is
really difficult and i guess that is
your job and at its highest form that is
what you do as a historian
well norman is
i really appreciate your valuable time
is truly an honor to talk to you and
thank you for um
taking us through a trip through some of
the worst parts of human history and uh
and talking about hope and love at the
end so i really appreciate your time
today great thank you thank you thank
you for having me
you